le désoeuvrement de ces jeunes ne peut
laisser les adultes indique a souvent
privés de moyens de distraction bon
nombre de garçons et filles sont réduits
a passé le plus clair de leur temps dans
des terrains vagues généralement aux
alentours des grands ensembles ou
déambulant à travers les rues des
vieilles cités à brest et dans d'autres
grandes villes de france le problème de
leurs vacances à trouver une solution
grâce à l'intervention des municipalités
des hauts fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'intérieur du ministère de la jeunesse
et des sports et de très nombreuses
bonnes volontés dans celle de la marine
nationale
aujourd'hui nous nous intéresserons plus
particulièrement à brest loisirs qui
offre aux jeunes gens mais dans la somme
modique de 5 francs couvrant leur
assurance obligatoire pour un mois la
possibilité de passer le mois d'août en
pratiquant le sport de leur choix
ping pong tennis ou judo ainsi ces
jeunes dont les parents travaillent ne
traîne plus dans les rues de la ville
sans but et sans jours les premiers qui
ont répondu à l'appel de brest loisirs
et ceux qui en ont entendu parler en
tant couru amenant chaque jour avec eux
que nous vos amis pour profiter de cette
heureuse initiative
la danse classique les scream ou le tir
à la cible
100 des façons très agréable de passer
le temps lévitation a le double avantage
de se pratiquer de l'autre côté de la
rade de brest après bairon voilà qui
offre l'occasion d'une belle promenade
en mer à bord du korrigan vedettes de la
marine nationale gracieusement mise à la
disposition des organisateurs des
moniteurs qualifiés veille à la bonne
exécution de chaque discipline à terre
des cours d'initiation à la voile sont
dispensés avant les travaux pratiques
auxquelles nous allons assister
cela d'ailleurs donné lieu à de
véritables régate que les jeunes
organisent entre eux dans la fameuse
rade de brest
voilà qui nous permet d'espérer le plus
voir le triste spectacle de la jeunesse
livrée à elle même